you
everyone is Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and I'm gonna try
another group of three puzzles and share
my thoughts along the way so this first
one we're playing is white
okay well Queens under fire this is the
first move I'm considering we also have
ensuing checks on g8 Queen check King
here Queen check on g8 yeah this is
looking like it's some mating puzzle hmm
oh my goodness
there might be a quiet move to start
this puzzle wow this seems appealing you
know King here Queen check King g7 and
then Queen g8 check and we push them
around and but I'm I'm pausing for a
moment here because I'm seeing away
where we can cut the King off first move
Queen g3 we still defend our Bishop and
we're threatening mate here as well as
Queen takes e5 mate there's two main
threats with Queen g3 controlling these
adjacent diagonals if we could get on it
Queen controlling the dark squares Queen
g3 how do you stop made against this
square here my first thought was Bishop
here but that's not stopping this mate
with Queen takes e5 Queen g3 that's a
pretty slick move the bishop can't stop
the Queen from going to a light Square
and a dark square so it could interfere
with getting to this light square but
can't stop the Queen from moving along a
dark diagonal Queen g3 the bishop can't
stop both made threats
it's up to the queen where can she move
where she defends both be five and g8
there isn't a square I should also point
out what made me shift gears it just it
ran through my head really quick there
but I was thinking d8 and then what made
me go into this variation with Queen g3
and I'm not certain that it's correct
just yet but what made me go in this
direction was seeing that if it's blacks
turn to move right now there isn't a
move black can make and give check to
the white king so that made me think
about quiet moves you don't have to go
right in for a forcing moves that can be
a quiet move there's nope there isn't
going to be any danger like multiple
checks and our King running around and
stuff like that so I think this is a
queen g3 if Queen to f8 we give a check
here Queen takes pawn the Queen would
have to block on g7 and then we run down
to e8 and then it's mate next move I
think this is it that is correct
oh okay so this is the only way to stop
mate you have to give up the Queen okay
yeah those two threats of g8 and e5 were
too much very very tempting to go in for
Queen to d8 and start looking at this
and the King running away I had even
gone as far as thinking about well maybe
pushing a pawn up if we could get the
king to g5 and stuff like that but yeah
first move a silent one but a deadly one
all right let's try puzzle - okay team
black I was ready to move really quick
just now thinking it was it was a mate
until I'm not looking at taking the
bishop that's probably not good because
you're running right into a double check
Knight takes pawn Knight takes either
pawn opens up the file I was thinking
Queen here and after King F - Queen g3
mate that's true but the King has
another option
King to g1 but we could take the bishop
in that case okay oh so we don't go to
h3 we go to square which limits the
Kings options the most not Queen h3 but
rather g4 King only has one option and
then Queen g3 okay every once in a while
you get one a mate puzzle and that one
turned out to be a million - okay let's
move on to the last one all right Wow
okay
it's interesting my first thought is I
did I haven't seen this puzzle before
once in a while you'll get the same
puzzle coming back around but not the
case here hmm
they'd have four check must be the start
whites ready to Queen what attacking
pieces do we have here Wow Knight here
check what is the fantastic follow-up
though after all I don't know King here
mmm there is a fantastic follow up hmm
excuse me on Knight f4 if let's say King
H - mm-hmm I'm King H - there's Queen to
e6 and if white is promoting the idea is
to give a check on h3 and then G to the
knight on this square I start to observe
these light squares a bit more closely
mm-hmm Knight f4 King g3 there's another
one to consider
hmm 9f working g3 what are you doing now
give another check night h5 I really
don't like this one
there's too many King moves to be
considering hmm I don't know Knight f4
it's got to be that to start right oh
wait a second why am I not looking at
this rook being captured maybe that
might be something huh yeah let's see
Knight f4 King g1 oh no that's not
working Knight f4 King g1 Queen takes
pawn and then mate next on g2 this must
be a start this has to be the first move
Knight f4 I have this one covered I have
this one covered as well Knight f4 King
did either of these two its Queen takes
pawn and then Queen the g2 mate Knight
now for King it h2 as well is Queen
takes pawn so on Knight f4 if King H 1 G
1 I should say night-night f4 if King h1
h2 or g1 it's the same move Queen takes
pawn leading to mate next so the only
one to consider after Knight f4 is king
g3 and on that the rook is unprotected
but I don't know this this should be
some mating problem because look at the
material quite soon to have a new queen
on board
I don't think scooping up the rook is
doing a whole lot unless it's going in
the direction of one day mating Knight
f4 King g3 Queen takes rook King takes
Knight or maybe even promoting next
hmm okay also another thing after Knight
f4 King g3 if we're not Swift
we're not quick enough rook h1 we're
getting in some trouble maybe hmm
Knight f4 King g3 and what are we doing
next we could give another check
let this be some Perpetual puzzle is
this the best that black can do we don't
know still looking for a win but with
white so close to queening this feels
like it should be a win for Black Knight
f4 King g3 our Knight his attack though
can we really give him up we could
defend them one quiet move but that
seems way too slow I mean for one you
could play I don't know rook h1
threatening to take the bishop and then
take the knight and the Queen alone
won't be enough to weave any mating net
huh I didn't consider Queen takes Knight
much because you just promote and that's
stopping and ensuing check here Knight
f4 king g3 is that what this is you just
go back here I think that's what it is
I don't see a win here tonight f4 king
g3 Queen takes rook Primeau Knight f4
king g3 Queen takes rook King takes
Knight I don't see how that's gonna help
I mean you give a check with the bishop
the but and the bishop could enter as an
attacker but yeah I don't know about
that
I've spent too long on this I'm gonna
say that it's uh I hate to say it but I
think it's I think it's a draw is this
really the best we could do
am I missing hmm night out let me give
it one more shot here
dig deep focus Knight f4 King g3 if I
don't get this puzzle I'm blaming it on
the bird that's in the background I
don't know if you could hear it turn up
the volume there's a bird in the
background he's saying come on get this
puzzle over with maybe it's a she
I'm distracted who said I'm not focused
anymore I'm not focused if I'm concerned
about the gender of the bird good grief
Knight f4 King g3 Queen takes rook I
don't think that leads to anything I'm
gonna say Knight f4 and then you jump
back here yeah I'm lazy okay it's that's
the correct start I knew that this is
the part that's tricky all right I vote
you go back here and that's the best
that you could do I can let me give it
one more shot now that it's advanced one
move Queen takes rook King takes Knight
I mean there's other choices too though
maybe there wouldn't be because there's
like like check here after Queen takes
rook if you don't take the knight then I
could come here with Chuck so Queen
takes rook King takes Knight Bishop
check I don't buy it
no because the King can run over here
I'm gonna say has to be this it is
correct
Oh ah man distracted by a bird No
good grief yeah you know I can't even
say that I have this one solved either
because there's other things that I
didn't consider like if the King is
going to this square on g4
this was really tough to know that there
really isn't something more than this
little perpetual let me go into the
analysis board real quick because I want
to look at this one variation which one
right here let me get it lined up this
position right here so after okay this
is where the puzzle started after push
Knight f4 King here Knight check if King
here maybe this pawn can contribute are
there's even other checks to that the
knight could be giving that's another
thing or Queen here with check this
might be a clean check and if the knight
is taken that's check and I was ready to
say that's checkmate but that's not the
case that's check and this would be
checkmate alright so that's a I think I
had that right that's a pretty cool line
if the King is jump we're going to the
g4 Square Queen check Knight taken and
if the knight isn't taken can't turn out
really well can it no probably not like
let me just show one I don't know King
here I'll show both actually there'd be
Bishop check and then faster mate or
maybe that's equal same number of moves
and the other one is if the King goes
here instead of taking the knight no
we'd still have this Bishop check
there's one other thing I'm not
considering though there's a knight
there's a knight block and reply to this
Queen check clean here what do you do
with the knight blocks you give a check
here and then you're going to be
capturing this Knight with checks in
King here we take here and that's
probably leading to me you know
certain point you could stop calculating
in fact now this rook could be taken
with some Forks can here just to point
out get the rook and there's no longer
any fear of a pawn promoting but yeah
very interesting a puzzle those are
tough because the temptation is
certainly where's the wind where's the
wind where's the wind but it's certainly
realistic because you know you don't
know just like in a regular game you
just don't know if there is a win in
some cases this is the best-case
scenario and I'm glad to have got it but
yeah feel free to share how you did with
these three puzzles in the comment
section below and I'll catch you in the
next video
take care
you
you